mathieu tu en bout de table c'est pas ma
place
un cadre assez on va t'expliquer
pourquoi nino qui est un ami proche d'un
proche qu'est ce qui s'est passé non je
envie de fumer dans une situation
délicate parce que j'adore mathieu et
c'est ma vraie bonne surprise de la
rentrée parce que tout le monde avant
que j'arrive me disait tu voir mathieu
il est prétentieux narcissique dos un
fourbe traître moi j'en ai encore un
match avait les bonnes
mais on s'entend très bien et il ya
juste un truc que j'ai pas trop aimé
quand je suis arrivé et moi j'ai je veux
pas trop en parler pour eux tu vas
mettre le bazar mais vas-y que non mais
j'ai pas envie qu'après en dise il vient
d'arriver le dira pas non franchement je
préfère bon je te le dis
en fait j'ai pas aimé comment il a mal
paraître son fils va me raconter je vous
racontais mathieu oui peu à sur votre
rue et des preuves de ça parce que
j'adore le petit nino
[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques jours donc moi je suis
arrivé à h2o personne ne me connaissait
et je croise mathieu qui ne savait pas
qui j'étais puisqu'il s'intéresse à
personne
et ce coup il est là il discute un peu
avec tout le monde était arrivé avec
lino genre de tournée la vidéo qu'on a
fait et
mathieu dans sa danse a je crois que
l'on peut dire dans sa bonté excessive
et ce à son honnêteté légendaire regarde
lino et commence à dire qu'est ce qu'il
est beau cet enfant il est magnifique il
est gentil pendant cyril rachète -
documentaire disney
il est dans son truc fois et la syrie
c'est là que c'est vrai que mathieu tu
m'a blessée parce que lino est un ami
avant tout au moment où vous êtes parti
dans l'ascenseur il s'est tourné vers
moi et il a dit je cite cet enfant était
exécrable je ne le supporte pas
je voulais tu revois dire ça
je suis c'est juste à ça sa marraine
pour lui on s'échange des des barres de
chocolat tu m'as vu faire j'ai des
témoins j'ai été très simple demain ou
après demain je pense que demain mon
fils yamaha vous répondre oui saber
direct ah oui très bien vous ferez une
confrontation avec mais bien sûr du côté
de cette confrontation d'un quart
d'heure nantes à
18h40 et de cette confrontation
prendra une décision lui et moi sont
votre avenir
c'est un monde de 8 ans car jamais rien
fait qui va décider de
[Applaudissements]
qui va venir vous partez 13 mai sera là
demain il décidera en son âme et
conscience si vous devez quitter
l'aventuré ou pas
ah oui voilà nino sera là demain à 18
heures 40 la décision et
je serai très intelligent ce moment
les séries les chéris ya mathieu je
trouve que j'ai ce barrage ans paraît
deux heures comme dirait pas là les deux
heures ah oui vous êtes non
je ne faisais pas de place donc soit
leur envie larmes en nous mais je m'en
vais mais qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce qui
va pas pourquoi silva fait il va pâtir
il ne va pas lui va pas le payer il va
nous appeler demain
[Rires]
je m'habille et
donc quadra demande pas si je peux
rester un petit peu
[Applaudissements]